no your your I know your father for the
left-wing resistance and was imprisoned
and was blacklisted and I personally I
don't know how the filmmakers and
writers here feel but I I find anger to
be a very useful emotion when I'm
working it is yeah it is I think we make
the movies to have feelings emotions
love cry love eight I think they hate
and it's sometimes a good good emotion
it would a good thing to have for some
situations of course it's and I think we
did we did that movie with that kind of
feeling would like to love sometimes
with those guys and then we used to hate
them
not only me but all the actors because
they knew the situation when I spoke to
them explain there were friends most of
them when I explained to them what I
would like to do they went well let's do
it and I said we don't have money to pay
you said oh no problem let's do it
anyway did you immediately have the
sense that it that you would have the
sort of wandering camera and you would
you would have this almost sensory
overload in the images at the beginning
you know believe is that the editing of
the movie you do it during the writing
of the script first thing and then you
make the movie you will be shooting and
of course you start thinking about the
editing then you do the editing of it
and I think you cannot date the movie if
you don't have the material so the music
yes we're doing the right of escape I
trying to listen music to to see who
would be good with the actors and what
kind of music oh yes yeah now the film
was of course shot in Algeria and
because you couldn't shoot it in Greece
did the fact that you were working in
French do you feel that that was did it
frustrate you that you couldn't make it
in the language that was your native
language or do you think in a way it
freed you because you were you know it
almost abstracted the politics into a
different into even even better and said
the way I asked you probably saw that I
don't use names right
music Greek names I just use functions
because to me is the general and the
lawyer the doctor
it's that makes the move in the same way
much more universal my my fear was to
make him move a kind of or chloric movie
about because you know what are we doing
the move nobody would believe that would
be a good movie nobody good buddy was
going to give us money we did it without
been paid most of the actors accepted
without in paid so our effort was to
make the movie as as good or you could
do it and that was all nobody could
believe that this movie would be what
happened what happened to it and to
verify because it was important not to
kind not to invent scenes it was
important to find the right things that
have been said the guy person who were
there at the right moment and different
situations so I went through different
witnesses of course the vice versa
because the one who wrote the book did
it before me and I did also myself later
doing the right movie script so it was
important to show different points of
view in that story and after you can see
it was one of the problems for thee for
the people who were producing money if
there is no main character right
you see if we speak about the movement
and I make a calculation the moment you
know if Montana in the movie it's for 12
and a half minutes that's all so it was
sort of a bait-and-switch eachother
financier say it's gonna be yeah a lot
of us have probably used that technique
in this in this room I read a quote
where you said the role of art is to
make visible what is not visible in
society and when I was watching the film
I always think more than there are these
cinemas all of the cinema because you
can see we watch we can learn we can
talk about things and we see human
beings like us or some others and for
that I think the role of the cinema is
very important in society there is a
French philosopher Alain Badiou used to
say all the movies are political or
there's politics in every movie all can
analyze the removal politically
and I'm sure of that completely sure so
I'm speaking I have human beings like
any removing human beings who have
problems I'm trying to explain their
problems and of course I'm facing I'm
facing the problem of the power who is
the power how he deals with power
whatever is missing or the confession or
or Z for example so and the way they use
the power can make us happy or Clara is
miserable and of course each one I to
extend that idea of mine all of us who
have some power to some people there are
people up above us so the way it was
that power is used make much happy or
miserable we are facing other power the
power of money the power of a few people
around the world who run am I feeling
they run completely our democracies I
think today the the power of money is
stronger than our people the people will
elect for to run the countries yeah but
also I was very lucky as a young
immigrant when arriving in France to met
extraordinary people like he's not
handsome on senior way and to be part of
the group Chris Mulcair some others show
sampran the writer so it was really very
lucky to discover that the politics were
not owned it was not they were not
should not be fanaticism should be we
have to be critical and to try to
understand and same for the for the art
for cinema the way we make in cinema why
are we making cinema and those things so
it was for young immigrant I was was a
big big lesson and then I was able to
work with some directors like Erina
Claire who was coming from the silent
movement and then a silent period of the
movies and then with Jacques Demy who
was the Nouvelle Vague so this also was
very important to me because I saw the
different ways of making movies or or or
conceiving movies also
you've managed to go effortlessly
between different cultures you know to
make a lot of it to make your films I my
personal example of that
I was in Uruguay recently and I was
giving a talk and I was sort of talking
about filmmakers that I admired and I
mentioned journey I said I said
costa-gavras and the audience sort of
cheered and if you don't know if you
don't know the film's state of siege you
you first of all should see it
immediately but state of siege is about
the tupamaros and and sort of the
political situation the guerrilla
situation in org Y and so I said this at
the talk and the next day I was invited
to meet the president because I
mentioned costa-gavras